i'm just trying to address a lot of fear
because i hear that argument a lot well
if you're just a wife you're gonna lose
yourself but if we keep feeding women
this narrative like they're gonna eat it
up and they're they're gonna buy it but
if you have a man who can protect
provide and cherish you it's like no
it's a no-brainer of course you're gonna
go ahead and pursue something like that
but women are always thinking oh i lose
something in a marriage i lose something
in a marriage i'm vulnerable i don't
think so i think men take the bigger
risk in assuming all of the
responsibility for finances within a
marriage if you look at the divorce
statistics it's pretty cut and dry so
like sometimes i hear
you know what happens if your husband
leaves you for someone younger i
actually don't worry about that because
i know how the family courts are it's
more so the fact that like my
women women's satisfaction in marriage
we have a lot more autonomy over that
than we think because we end up leaving
most of the time i think 80 of the time
women are the ones causing the divorce
it's 90 of your college educated